you know if i wanted to demonstrate the
dire state of conservatism today i would
probably need to only point to this one
fact
there is a woman who calls herself a
conservative porn star
and she has legions of quote-unquote
conservative fans
including prominent conservatives and
media brandy love is her name she's 48
years old somehow making the whole thing
even more embarrassing and pathetic
and along with posting hardcore porn
online including on twitter where users
as young as 13 can easily access it
she's also fashioned herself as a
champion of the conservative cause
in which role she has authored a few
editorials that have been published by
the federalist
i don't know i'm not aware of any other
conservative activism she's done but
there's that
now i was unaware of this person's
existence blissfully so i might add
until this past weekend when controversy
was ignited by brandy love's attendance
at turning point usa's
student action summit tpusa that's
charlie cook
kirk's organization and this is their
conference that they do every year for
students that's what they call the
student action summit right there in the
name
now love a real name tracy livermore
initially showed up at the press
conference at the conference rather
four conservative high school and
college students with a vip badge
the impression that this gave of course
and the way it was reported on social
media and by some outlets like newsweek
is that she was specifically invited or
welcomed
by tpusa and that's why she had the vip
badge now that wasn't the case
she purchased the vip ticket showed up
on her own accord
and began posting to her to her twitter
page in between photos of her genitals
and so forth
there were also pictures of her walking
around the event posing in front of fox
news banners
and expressing her enjoyment at being
around so many quote young conservatives
tpusa however did not enjoy having her
as much as she enjoyed being there
once the event uh organizers realized
who she was and what she did and why she
was there
they kindly asked her to leave and this
is how they explain that decision to
newsweek this is what they said
quote turning point usa uh this is
according to the
tpusa spokesman turning point usa did
not block miss love from its student
event
because of backlash tpusa did so in
keeping with its standard operating
procedures to not involve porn brands
influencers or personalities that post
or publish sexually explicit and
pornographic content
a few concerned parents rightly alerted
us to the extremely pornographic nature
of her social media posts
and event leadership immediately took
the appropriate steps in keeping with
the best interests of the minors present
at the event
furthermore miss love purchased an adult
vip ticket she was not invited nor was
her attendant somehow requested by the
organization
the bottom line is that it is simply not
appropriate for a porn star to be
actively posting images at an event with
15 and 16 year olds present
in conjunction with graphic pornography
tpusa makes no apology for this a
position which should not be
controversial especially
when minors are involved parents deserve
this type of assurance and tp uso
intends
on giving them that confidence any
controversy is purely contrived
all right that's the whole statement
everything that you just heard there
could not possibly be more reasonable
they're holding an event for
conservative teenagers
they don't wish to welcome a vip guest
who is actively in the hardcore porn
business
and who will post images of herself at
the event alongside images of her vagina
they also don't wish to become a forum
for a cyber prostitute
which is what a porn star is to directly
promote her business to minors or to
anyone else at their event
this is again a conservative conference
for students
tracy livermore put them in an
uncomfortable position by choosing to
show up without any warning without
asking without checking with them first
and the embarrassment of getting kicked
out on her ass is therefore her own
fault
you don't even have to be anti-porn to
understand the basic concept here
and to recognize who the bad guy in the
situation is
but many on the right have struggled to
understand this
although livermore is clearly 100 to
blame
and tpusa did absolutely nothing wrong
and conducted itself
well in this case still so many
conservatives felt otherwise
the the organization is being attacked
today from the right
for daring to make a 48 year old
hardcore porn star
feel unwelcome at their event for
conservative teens
prominent conservatives have jumped on
the the dog pile as well ben
dominus who's the co-founder of the
federalist he's also husband of
megan mccain he tweeted quote i'm
disappointed that tpusa kicked out
brandy love for no reason whatsoever
she's a florida conservative
businesswoman
who loves america the right has an
opportunity to be the big
tent party don't be a bunch of prudes
businesswoman doing a lot of work in
that sentence i think
nick ciercy who's a conservative actor
with a large following also defended
livermore arguing that
you aren't being like jesus if you agree
with tpusa on its decision
apparently jesus thinks that 48 year old
hardcore porn stars
should totally be vip guests at
conferences for teenagers
at least we should say nick has made
that assumption about jesus christ and
is comfortable
putting those words into his mouth these
arguments were echoed on social media by
many on the right
including livermore herself where she
spent the following
day or two painting herself as the
victim complaining about how she was
treated quoting the bible
in her own defense and arguing that
conservatives who oppose pornography or
the attendance of a pornographer at a
conservative student conference
are jackasses fools prudes etc
she also posted more pictures of her
genitals so
in between quoting the bible she's
posting pictures of her genitals no
problem there
now let's try to sort through this and
inject a little bit of sanity into the
proceedings if we can
and to that end a few points i think
need to be made
number one to reiterate
just considering the business and pr
concerns here alone
it is perfectly understandable that a
conservative activist group
that works with minors would not want a
woman with her porn star stage name on
her vip
pass walking around the place taking
pictures and meeting quote fans
if livermore had any respect for anyone
and cared about anything or anyone but
herself
she would have contacted tp usa ahead of
time anticipating the uncomfortable
position she might be putting them in
and asked them if if she could attend
she didn't take this step and the fact
that she didn't only proves that she
couldn't care less how her presence
impacts the event or the organization
that's holding it
which is just one more reason why that
organization has no obligation
to let her stay here's a basic concept
if you choose to make your living by
having sex on camera
and posting pictures of your genitals on
social media
if that's how you choose that's what you
choose to do
you can't be offended when people don't
want to be associated with you
it's not as though you were born a porn
star
this isn't a genetic defect it's not a
biological identity it's not your race
or your ethnicity
no i'm being discriminated against no
people are reacting to your choices
sweetheart you also aren't a desperate
poor
sex trafficked 18 year old you're a 48
year old woman
who has chosen to make a lot of money
this way doing very well for yourself
you may say you have the right to
prostitute yourself online for money and
you do
legally according to our laws at the
moment
but uh people and organizations also
have the right to not want to associate
with you
that doesn't make you a victim grow up
number two this all bleeds i think into
a broader conversation about
conservatism and and what it stands for
or doesn't stand for and as this
incident demonstrates
though we knew this already um there are
some conservatives
many i think who think that uh
conservatism should embrace
and defend the normalization of hardcore
pornography
to a lot of conservatives today uh if if
you
not only should you defend hardcore
pornography but it's like absurd if you
don't it's ridiculous not to
you're just a prude in fact if you don't
think that a hardcore porn star
should be at an event for conservative
16 year olds
you're a prude according to
conservatives
they don't think that being conservative
should necessarily mean um
that that you know we have to be critics
of the porn industry
or even of a porn star showing up at an
event like this of course 40 years ago
this would not have been a discussion
you wouldn't have been able to find any
self-proclaimed conservative
anywhere who would defend hardcore porn
in principle as a thing fully in keeping
with conservative values as just a
legitimate form of business that's all
now many conservatives will do just that
because the left has shifted the whole
culture in its direction
so thoroughly and dramatically that
conservatives will adopt radically
leftist positions
while imagining that they're opposing
the left in the process
you might compare it i guess to the
situation encountered by
early arctic explorers attempting to
reach the north pole they would they
would walk for miles
imagining that they're going north but
the ice beneath them was drifting south
so they were going one way while the
ground they stood on went the other
well in our culture the ground we stand
on stand on drifts ever left which means
that
if your version of being right wing is
simply to be slightly to the right
of what qualifies right now as left wing
then you will at best be the right wing
of the left wing
which is what a lot of the people on the
right really are
they are the right wing of america's
left wing
that's why you got to be philosophically
and ideologically grounded in something
deeper if if all
if if you're grounding doesn't go any
deeper
than the ice you're standing on then
when that whole chunk is shifting you're
shifting along with it
along with the cultural tide
uh all of the conservatives who imagine
that they're
conserving something while embracing
what what would have been considered
radical by the left
20 years ago are evidence of this
problem
here's the point the normalization of
sexual degeneracy
is a leftist position
and uh and in fact i'll amend that a
little bit
it's not only a leftist position it is
in fact
the principal leftist position
it's the main thing that they're trying
to do
it's the primary thing that animates
them is the normalization of sexual
degeneracy
you cannot fight leftists while
embracing
their primary foundational doctrine
you're agreeing with them on the thing
that they consider to be
the most important thing
which is the normalization of sexual
degeneracy
and the idea that you know sexually you
should be able to do whatever you want
and live however you want
and uh not only should you be able to
but it should be celebrated and accepted
by everyone
you cannot fight the left you can't
really stand for anything least of all
freedom
or whatever you think you're standing
for if you've abandoned
moral truth
if conservatism seeks to conserve
anything
that's what it has to conserve right
first and foremost
truth of all kinds moral truth included
and biological truth we should note
but when you look at what's happened in
conservatism even just over the last
couple of months
we've had self-proclaimed conservatives
embracing caitlyn jenner
and self-proclaimed conservatives a lot
of them the same ones
uh now saying oh yeah have hardcore porn
stars at the
conservative events let's prove how cool
we are
a total abandonment of moral truth and
biological truth of truth of all kinds
and then where are you left what do you
think you're doing exactly
what's the ne what's the next step here
okay the goal is to let's defeat the
left step one
abandon moral truth step two abandon
biological truth
and then what victory okay then we got
step three
question marks step four victory what
goes in step three there
you've joined them you've given them
everything you imbecile
you've given them everything they want
and you'll oppose them now because uh
well yeah we give them
everything that matters we've given them
truth we've given them morality
we've adopted their fundamental outlook
on life
but we believe in lower taxes
what i would like for someone to do
is explain
break it down for me what exactly are
you conserving
what are you trying to conserve
if not truth first and foremost
and if you can't come up with an answer
to that then i would suggest that you
and i
are not even on the same side well i
hope you enjoyed that clip from the matt
well show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content